let's talk about the race to become
Brazil's next president
that really comes down to just two men
the current president jair bolsonaro
[Applause]
okay he is seen as the Trump of the
Trump
the former president Luis Ignacio Lula
de Silva
[Applause]
he's both the most loved and the most
hated politician in Brazil may be
seconded by variable sonar Lula's ahead
in the polls and the big question is
whether he can win outright in the first
round he'll need more than 50 percent of
votes to do that or it'll go to a second
round runoff and if bolsonaro loses it
doesn't look like he'll go quietly
he's already been talking about election
fraud bolsonaro has challenged the very
validity of the electoral process to
keep flirting with a coup
sometimes he says it explicitly
sometimes he just can't said it so who
are these two Rivals and why are
Brazilians so divided over them
[Music]
is bolsonaro and Lula represent a right
versus left-wing rivalry but there's
also so much more going on and a good
place to start is the early 2000s Lulu
became president in 2003 and served two
terms until 2010.
he was a former union leader and
Brazil's first working-class president
it was a time when the economy was
booming and for a lot of Brazilians life
got better there was the Commodities
super cycle that made a lot of dollars
come to Brazil his administration also
did a lot of measures to protect
low-income families Lula left office
with an 83 percent approval rating the
next president jilma Rousseff was from
the same Workers Party the PT and was
seen as Lula's hand-picked successor
president Rousseff
Uma Rousseff was enjoying a pretty high
approval rates at the time and all of a
sudden Brazil went into this long-term
model and one of the big questions that
many people ask is uh what happened to
Brazil after 2013 well a couple of big
things happened first the economy turned
there was a recession people were losing
their jobs and prices were going up and
then there was Operation Car Wash what
became a huge corruption investigation
that went on for years it basically
uncovered a multi-billion dollar money
laundering and bribery scheme linked to
the state-run oil company petrobras they
revealed during the car wash operation
that there was a an involvement of
pretty much every single major political
party in Brazil with corruption
standards that included Lula himself in
2017 he was convicted of money
laundering and Corruption and ended up
with a 12-year prison sentence although
he was released after about 18 months
Oola maintained he'd done nothing wrong
and that all the charges were
politically motivated and by the way the
Supreme Court later annulled his
convictions
so let's look at the last presidential
election in 2018. it was a really messy
time in Brazil the economy was
recovering from a deep recession the
corruption Scandal was going strong and
violent crime was on the rise and that's
where jaid bolsonaro comes in
[Music]
1990
heavyweight but he got a lot of
attention for making statements like
this
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
on a platform all about making Brazil
great again he was up against Lula who
was campaigning from jail until he was
barred at the last minute
and Bolson Auto one
bolsonaro seem to be
as early as 2016 or 17. the the man who
embodied all the frustration and all the
bad blood that was going around Brazil
at the times and his platform was uh
music to many people's ears at that
point so he would say that he
um he was an anti-system candidate he
was fighting corruption he has mastered
political communication on social media
like no one else in Brazil especially no
one on the left and he he has
successfully shaped a lot of
conversations in the country
that's what allowed him to go from back
venture to a competitive presidential
candidate to the being the president now
some Brazilians look back at the last
four years of bolsonaro as president and
see disaster many blame him for not
taking covet seriously more than 680
000 Brazilians died the second highest
death toll in the world
then there's his environmental record
deforestation has accelerated under
bosonato and he's rejected the idea that
Brazil has any special role to play in
the fight against climate change
and then there's the accusation that
bolsonaro has deliberately weakened
State institutions bolsonaro has moved
very quickly ever since the very
beginning of his tenure to undermine and
to hollow out uh to political
institutions and bureaucracies
especially those who might put
obstacles or limits to the actions of
some private interest groups that have
supported bolsonaro from day one but a
lot of Brazilians really like what
bolsonaro stands for he's seen as more
supportive of the private sector and
he's got a lot of support among people
with more conservative social values
foreign
those that vote for bolsonaro they don't
want people to be talking about gender
identity in school they don't want
abortion definitely they don't want
drugs to be legalized uh they'd rather
not have gay rights
these people there are people that
believe in this agenda so in this
election with bolsonaro up against Lula
you've got this epic political Showdown
both of them are huge personalities both
are controversial in their own way and
both of them Inspire love and hate from
different parts of society
but putting the political theater aside
for a moment the big issue for most
Brazilian voters is the economy because
a lot of people are struggling right now
more than half the population is food
insecure even though Brazil is one of
the world's biggest food producers and
prices are going up for food and fuel
just like in many other countries
[Music]
in Brazil have been extremely
challenging especially for lower income
voters who are the majority of the
Brazilian population so that's why the
economy is the number one number two and
number three priority for voters so both
candidates are trying to convince voters
that they're the man to deliver on the
economy bolsonaro has been pointing out
that inflation and unemployment have
gone down and in July he got Congress to
approve 7.6 billion dollars in emergency
aid that includes a 50 increase in
monthly cash payments for Brazil's
poorest until the end of the year as for
Lula he's been pushing the message that
the economy was much better back when he
was president
um
[Music]
he's able to tap into people's uh
perception that their lines were better
back in 2010 and
the the fact that is that it was that
people's lives were definitely better
Lula has basically run on the platform I
know how to do stuff I have done in the
past and I'm not both Ronaldo but that
works the other way around too with some
people supporting bolsonaro just because
he's not Lula there are people who vote
for bolsonaro because they hate Lula
these are people that are furious at the
corruption scandals and they feel that
they're now having to pick between a
crazy guy and uh and uh and a robber
it's like
which one would I rather have all of
this is creating a really tense election
atmosphere
there's even been violence
two Lula supporters have been killed by
bolsonaro supporters and bolsonaro
doesn't seem to be doing much to calm
things down he's been questioning the
voting machines and setting up the idea
that there could be fraud he's trying to
sew this trust in the country's
electronic voting system which in almost
30 years has never faced one single
credible fraud allegation in bosonado
has swamped the Brazilian public
discourse with vitriol he has portrayed
this electoral race as the battle
between good and evil so there's a lot
of nervousness in Brazil about the state
of the country right now and where this
election could take things what I feel
about this election is like there's no
there's no hope for the future it's more
of an election like let's avoid falling
into a hole so people are clinging on to
what they think will be less worse and
not
something that will be better sometimes
I have the feeling that uh we have two
separate and very different results uh
that no longer talk to each other start
here breaks down the big news stories
and you can watch more of our episodes
on altazira's YouTube channel like this
one about what's going on in Afghanistan
one year after the Taliban took over
[Music]